Let me repeat a point I made in the
previous session. Everything in
scripture points to Jesus. And every
historical event, every historical
event, these are true historical events.
They're not fiction. True historical
events, but they were designed,
orchestrated, carried along by God in
such a way to point to greater spiritual
truths, spiritual realities. So now I'm
probably going to have to read Bible
verses for you. So let me get my Bible
ready. I'm using biblegateway.com. I'll
be using
New King James Version. Keep in mind
Leviticus chapter 15. Keep that in mind.
We're not going to read all of it. We
can't read all of it. Leviticus chapter
15. Keep in mind Leviticus chapter 15.
Keep in mind Leviticus chapter 13. Keep
these in mind. We can't read them. and
Holy Spirit perfect my ability to recall
these passages. So keep in mind
Leviticus chapters 13,4 and 15. Just
keep those chapters in mind. Now let's
begin. Today Shahbel told me they're
celebrating
the feast of the woman
who had a bleeding disorder for 12
years.
Right? the sherbel here because I'm
going to now use that to glorify Jesus.
You want spiritual meat? Let's unpack
spiritual meat. Right. Today is the
feast of the woman who had a bleeding
disorder for 12 years. Okay. Note Luke
8:40.
Luke 8:40
to 55.
Also found in Mark 5 from 30 all the way
down and Matthew 9. This story is found
in Matthew chapter 9, Mark 5, Luke 8.
Matthew 9 gives you a summation, a
summary, succinct summary. It is Mark
and Luke that give you more details.
Now, let me bring out the significance.
Okay? When you go to Luke 8:40
to 55, we're not going to quote it. I'm
going to sum up and you can read it at
your own leisure. It says, "Jyrus, who
was a synagogue ruler, sent for Jesus,
saying, "Come, my daughter is dying."
Okay.
Gyrus's daughter was 12 years old.
Okay. As he's going to Gyrus's house, a
crowd is following him. It says, "A
woman with a bleeding disorder
came and quietly,
stealthily touched the fringes of his
garment and walked away. The moment she
touched him, she was instantly healed."
And then power came out of Jesus's body.
And then he turned and looked at her, it
says, "Who touched me?" Now, people
think Jesus is asking because he doesn't
know. Well, let me show you why that's
not the case. You will often find in
scripture where the triune God will ask
questions not because he doesn't know in
order to get you to confess in order to
get you repent or to show how wicked and
evil you are that when you're confronted
instead of confessing you still lie you
still excuse your behavior and you still
cover up your shame.
Okay,
let me repeat.
God often asks questions in order to get
you to confess, profess, acknowledge, or
to show how evil and corrupt you are
that even when you're confronted by God,
you will lie. You will justify and cover
up your shame. Let me prove that that
Jesus is not asking or God doesn't ask
because he doesn't know. In Genesis 4,
God says to Cain right after he kills
Abel, "Where is your brother Cain?" He
goes, "How should I know? Am I my
brother's keeper? What have you done?
The blood of your brother cries out to
me.
See, God knew. So why is he asking? To
show us the reader, because this story
would be preserved and recorded. To show
us the reader,
look how evil and filthy and corrupt and
satanic Cain had become. Not only did he
think he could lie to God and get away
with it, assuming that God didn't see
all things, when confronted, he covers
up his sin and shame and doesn't
confess, showing that God's judgment of
him was deserved. You caught it?
Another example, we're not going to
quote it, but I'm just going to sum it
up. In John 21:15-17,
John 21:15-17,
Jesus asked Simon Peter, Simon son of
John, do you love me more than these the
fish? Because they had just come back
from fishing. Yes, Lord, you know I love
you. Feed my sheep. Simon son of John,
do you love me more than these? Yes,
Lord, you know I love you. Take care of
my lamb lambs.
Simon, son of John, do you love me more
than these? And then it says, Simon was
hurt. John 21:17, Simon was hurt when he
asked him the third time, "Do you love
me?" He goes, "Lord, you know I love
you. Lord, you know all things. You're
omnisient. You know my heart. You know
everything. You know I love you. Then
care for my sheep." All right. Notice
Jesus didn't ask because he didn't know.
Because if he didn't know, he would ask
the first time, "Get the answer and
stop." Right?
So why did Jesus ask him? Because Jesus
wanted him to verbally publicly confess
his love in front of the other apostles
in order to restore him for every time
he publicly denounced him. You deny me
three times in front of others. You will
confess your love for me three times in
front of others because this is the way
of my restoring you
in love and compassion and mercy.
You see why he did it? For each time you
denied me, you denied me three times in
front of others. I will restore you by
having you confess your love for me
as a sign of repentance and restoration
for every time you denied me.
Okay. So now coming back to the woman,
the woman is bleeding for 12 years.
She's been bleeding for as long as
Gyrus's daughter has been alive.
Guys, Gyrus's daughter
was 12 years old and she was dying. The
woman was bleeding for as long as
Gyrus's daughter was alive.
You caught it or no? Before I move on,
are you seeing the connection between
Gyrus's daughter and the woman with a
bleeding disorder of 12 years? The woman
was bleeding for as long as Gyrus's
daughter was alive. She was 12 and she
was dying. The woman was bleeding for 12
years. The flow of blood
when you are bleeding, that's a sign
that you're dying and perishing and life
is ebbing away.
Are you with me there? Your life is
ebbing away. You're dying. How do I
know? Leviticus 17:11. Leviticus 17:11
says,
"The soul of the flesh is in the blood.
The life of the flesh is in the blood. I
have therefore given you the blood on
the altar to make atonement for your
souls. For the soul of the flesh is the
blood. Notice the blood is what sustains
your soul in your body. As you're
bleeding,
your soul exits your body. God has
designed it. Pay attention. God has
designed that your soul will only remain
in your body to animate your body as
long as the blood is in it. Once the
blood is drained, God has ordered that
the soul leave your body. So your soul
then leaves your body. Your body returns
to the dust and your soul is still
conscious and alive. But what is the
soul of the flesh? What keeps the soul
in your body to keep your body animated?
The blood. When you drain the victim of
blood, that forces the soul to exit out
of your body and your body returns to
the dust. Maj just block all the demons
because Satan's children are coming but
the Lord Jesus crushed Satan and his
children.
Okay,
everyone with me there.
So the woman bleeding for 12 years meant
that her life was ebbing away. She was
dying. So make the connection with
Gyrus's daughter. My daughter is dying.
The woman is bleeding. Dying. Bleeding.
both point to both of them dying,
perishing,
slipping away.
I'm going very slow so you can get it.
Do you catch it? She's dying. Gyrus's
daughter, the woman is bleeding. to be
bleeding, for blood to
flow out of your body, that's a sign of
death, that you are dying and your life
is ebbing away and your soul is
departing from you. So Gyrus's daughter
is dying. The woman is bleeding. So
what's the connection? They're both
women. They're they're they're both
dying, slipping away, ebbing away, and
the woman is bleeding for as long as
Gyrus's daughter has been alive.
Okay, we all know Israel's called a
woman. Jeremiah 4:31, and she's the
bride of God. So, let's make the
connection. Israel is a woman, the bride
of God.
Israel. It consists of 12 tribes.
A woman bleeding for 12 years. A young
girl 12 years old. H coincidence.
The woman and Gyrus's daughter are a
picture of Israel.
Israel is dying. Israel is defiled.
She's dying. And though the woman, it
says the woman went to many doctors,
they could not cure her. Many prophets
were sent to her and could not cure her.
Her only hope of being saved from death
is if Israel clings to Jesus, reaches
out for Jesus, then the life of Jesus
will restore her and make her alive.
That's the point of the stories.
That's the point.
Do you caught it now?
The woman is an actual woman. She's
actually bleeding. She actually went to
doctors. But remember what I said.
Remember what I said. Everything is
there to point to a greater reality, a
spiritual truth. Miracles are not just
done for the sake of miracles. They're
done to bring out a greater spiritual
reality.
Okay? Why a woman bleeding for 12 years?
Why young girl 12 years old? Because
Israel is depicted as a woman. In fact,
in Ezekiel 16, if you read it, verses
18, God describes the birth of Israel,
the nation, as a young baby girl
abandoned to die in the desert. God
found that young baby girl and he spoke
life to her, right? He cleansed her of
her blood, sustained her from dying. And
then it says in Ezekiel 16 that he
waited for her to attain the age of
love. And when she had reached past
puberty, he then covered her with her
garment and married her. That's Ezekiel
16.
Ezekiel 16, chapter 16.
You caught it there. So even there, God
likens Israel to a baby girl, an infant
girl whose parents abandoned the
wilderness to die. God seeing her, loved
her, picked her up, revived her,
cleansed her of her blood and filth,
sustained her, waited for her to reach
maidenhood, to become a woman, a fully
blossomed woman, so then he could marry
her and make her his wife.
you there? You you with me so far? You
thank Sherel for mentioning this so I
can unpack this. And don't forget in
Leviticus 15, women with bleeding
disorders were ceremonially unclean.
They could not come into contact with
anyone. They had to be quarantined.
People had to be kept away from them.
That means this woman, pay attention
here. Why did this woman come stealthily
to touch Jesus's fringes? Because as far
as the the law is concerned, she could
not come in contact with anyone. People
had to avoid her like the plague. Like
if you have COVID 19, you have to be
quarantined. So that means this poor
woman for 12 years had to live in
isolation. No one could get near her or
touch her. So she was quarantined for 12
years without the benefit of someone
having fellowship with her, someone
spending time with her, someone hugging
her and affirming her and loving her.
She was all alone.
So why did the Lord then say, "Who
touched me?" Not because he didn't know.
He wanted to tell her, "Don't be
ashamed. Don't be afraid. I won't cast
you out. I won't reject you. I won't
rebuke you. I won't condemn you because
I came to make you whole and heal you
and save you. That's why he said to the
woman, "Woman, go. Your faith has saved
you. Your faith has healed you."
Okay,
that's Luke 8:44-48. You don't need to
post yet, Arthur. Not yet, Arthur. I'll
have you post a little later.
So, what's the connection? woman
bleeding for 12 years. Gyrus's daughter
12 and she's dying.
Dying. Okay, so she's bleeding just as
long just as long as Gyrus's daughter is
alive. Why women? Why 12? Israel
depicted as a baby girl who grew into
maidenhood fully blossomed as a woman
whom God marry and Israel consists of 12
tribes. So the picture of Gyrus's
daughter and the woman is a picture of
Israel. The woman went to many
physicians. They could not heal her.
Israel had many prophets sent to her who
could not heal her. Israel's only hope
now is to reach out by faith like that
woman and cling to Jesus and trust in
Jesus and he will make her whole and
save her from dying.
Now, let's go to Gyrus's daughter. Are
you guys getting me? Prepare for Sunday
worship.
Now, when you read Luke 8, it says she's
dying and before Jesus arrives at the
house, the servants come out and say to
Gyrus, "Don't trouble the master
anymore. She's dead." Jesus looked at
him and said, "Do not fear. Have faith.
She's not dead. She's asleep.
And they mocked him and they laughed at
him. They laughed at him. So he went
into the room where the young girl lay.
He brought in Peter, James, and John and
her parents. And it says he touched her
by the hand. Luke 8:54:55.
And he says, "Little girl, I say to you,
arise." And then it says, "Her spirit
returned to her and she awoke."
When Jesus touched her, her spirit that
left her body entered her body and she
was alive. She awoke. And he says, "Give
her something to eat." Now in Mark, Mark
gives you the Aramaic. In Aramaic, Jesus
says,
which translated means, "Young maiden,
arise."
Okay. Okay. Now, why is that important?
Because what Jesus is showing you is
Israel is dying and if it reaches out to
me, I will heal Israel and save her from
death. But even if Israel dies, I am
still able to resurrect Israel to be a
nation before me.
I have power over dying and death. I can
stop you from dying or I can awaken you
from death because Jesus is the God over
all creation. He is the God in whose
hand is life and death.
Everyone got that? Before I move on, I
don't want to be too loud, Lord, for my
neighbors. Do you understand what you're
supposed to learn from this? Israel is
dying and the Lord can save Israel from
death.
But even when Israel dies as a nation
before him as it did because he
destroyed the temple in Jerusalem and
scattered the Jews, taking away the
kingdom from them and giving it to the
church, God is still able to resurrect
the nation from their death and restore
them and make make them his people once
again.
Now does everyone understand the